SPARKY RHODE: Once again, it's
Wednesday afternoon in lovely,
sunny Europe.
I'm Sparky in Munich, Germany.
I'm joined by Matt and
Nick in London, UK.
NICK: Hello.
MATT: Hi.
SPARKY RHODE: It's 3:00
here in Munich.
It's 2:00 in London.
And we're here to talk about
Android app development.
So with that, I see that we've
got Andrew Kelly in the
Hangout, and he's also had a
question prepared for us.
I don't know if I have the
answer, but let's hear it.
ANDREW KELLY: I had two
questions today, actually.
One was to do the action bar and
the overflow menu items.
On things like Gingerbread,
whenever I use the Menu key,
sort of the hard Menu key on a
device, I can see a little
icon next to each of the
items in the menu.
But on Gingerbread, and sorry--
on Ice Cream Sandwich
and Jelly Bean, those icons
seemed to disappear.
I was just wondering if
that's intentional
or a bug in my code.
NICK: No, that's working
as intended.
ANDREW KELLY: OK, cool.
Is there any reason why they
decided to get rid of those?
NICK: I don't know.
It's probably a question
for the UX team.
But they decided that
the Overflow menu
would just be textual.
ANDREW KELLY: OK.
That was a simple answer.
NICK: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: If you look in the
Moderator, I believe that
I hit upon the correct answer
right away, which was to say
I'll let Nick answer this.
[CHUCKLES]
NICK: And there it was.
MATT: Designed very nice.
NICK: Yeah you can--
I've seen other applications
override it and do more
interesting menus.
I think Chrome, for example,
does some stuff where it puts
the first overflow items
is actually--
it's the forward, back, and
star buttons, I think.
So it tends to make it a little
bit more creative with
iconography.
So it's possible to kind of
override the implementation
and do something with
iconography if that's super
important to you.
But I would probably stick to
the platform default unless
you have good reasons
to deviate.
ANDREW KELLY: I just wanted to
make sure it wasn't a bug,
that's all.
Cool.
SPARKY RHODE: I have to say,
reserving the icons for the
action bar gives you, I think,
maybe a little more incentive
to put your colorful and
interesting actions out there
and not hide them
in the overflow.
NICK: Well I don't know.
Yeah.
It's also quite important to
provide text and icons for
everything because of the way
the action bar works with the
ifRoom and so on.
You can't guarantee
deterministically how many
icons are going to be showing
depending on the device and
platform changes and all
this good stuff.
So, yeah, it's super important
to provide a title even if you
just have an icon, and you
say always show this.
Because that same title text
will be used for the long
press tool tip.
So it's just really important
to provide both really.
SPARKY RHODE: You've got
the floor, Andrew.
Do you want to ask your
other question?
ANDREW KELLY: As long as I'm
here, I might as well.
I was just trying to work out
if there's a way of doing
animated launcher icons or icons
that can change on maybe
a given date.
Like a calendar app might have
an icon that would say, the
third, the second.
The actual date would be part
of the launcher icon.
I'm just trying to work out if
there's a clever way of either
animating launcher icons or
having them change over time.
NICK: So there's no built-in
support for this.
There's no API for this.
But you could probably do
something clever slash evil by
using package manager dot enable
set component enabled.
So if you think about it, your
application is just--
the icon in the launcher is just
an intent receiver as for
the home-main, intent
filters, right?
So I guess you could create 31
of those, each of which points
to the same activity that has
a different icon defined.
And then have some kind of
alarm which uses Package
Manager to enable disable.
I caution you, because it sounds
like a hack, and it's
probably going to
break things.
Like if you try and
put a shortcut--
well not probably, it
will break things.
If you try to put a shortcut
on your home screen, for
example, disabling the
component, which usually drop
from the home screen, enabling
another one which looks
similar is going to break it.
It's probably going to break it
in all kinds of other ways.
There's ways you could do
it, but probably not.
I would probably would
say, think about
maybe having a widget.
So obviously it won't change
in the launcher in
the all apps tray.
But on the home screen, you
could have an icon which
changed daily and get
close enough.
ANDREW KELLY: I don't know if
there's a way I could extend
the animated drawable or to have
it automatically call the
start method on the animation
and just point to that in my
manifest XML file
or something.
But I was unsuccessful
trying to get that
kind of thing to work.
NICK: Yeah.
I'm not surprised.
I don't think that is
a supported use
case for the launcher.
SPARKY RHODE: I'd be curious
to find out if some of the
third party launcher
replacements do that, or if
they support that capability.
I am fuzzing up today.
We're having camera hunting
problems here.
NICK: Who else have
we got joined us?
Is that Paul?
SPARKY RHODE: Paul Hanson
is in the hang out.
Welcome Paul.
What's up?
PAUL HANSON: Hello?
Can you hear me OK?
I can never tell if this is
working, because I haven't got
the video feed.
NICK: No worries.
PAUL HANSON: Things are good?
Thank you for getting back to
me, Nick, the other day.
I've just been spending quite
a while trying to get AVM up
and running with the codes.
So it's taking me a while trying
to get proper VM done.
So I'm going to implement
that quite soon.
Otherwise, I've got a few things
to ask, but they're not
in a very easy-to-ask format.
So I might hang on until
later in the show.
NICK: OK.
PAUL HANSON: And I see you're
doing a talk, Nick, at the
developer conference
next week.
NICK: Which one?
PAUL HANSON: The Droidcon.
Is there another
one in London?
NICK: No.
Next week I'm going
to be there.
I'm just an attendee
at Droidcon.
I won't be speaking.
Matt here will be talking.
MATT: Yup.
I'll be talking about
Google TV.
PAUL HANSON: What's the topic?
MATT: Some [INAUDIBLE]
Google TV.
And at the moment, I'm probably
going to be doing
some stuff on the [INAUDIBLE]
protocol and some of the cool
stuff you can do with that.
PAUL HANSON: I'm looking forward
to meeting everybody
and meeting up with some Google
types down there.
NICK: Cool, awesome.
I'll just be hanging out,
meeting you guys, talking
Android stuff, I guess.
PAUL HANSON: Oh brilliant.
NICK: Yeah.
It should be good.
Come say hi.
PAUL HANSON: I definitely
will.
I've got a few more
things at NFC.
I might send you a message
before the conference, because
I know you've got your contact
that knows all these things.
NICK: Yes.
Sure.
Why not?
PAUL HANSON: Cheers.
I'll definitely see
you next week.
NICK: Feel free if you do
want to ask questions.
I would much rather take live
questions from a person who
can clarify and respond and make
sure we're on the right
track than go through
[INAUDIBLE] ones.
PAUL HANSON: I've
got one thing.
I've not got it fully prepared
this time, because I was on
holiday last week.
One question I do have generally
is if Google or
Android's been preparing
for Trusted Execution
environments.
Does that ring any bells
with anybody?
NICK: Are you talking
about ARM TrustZone
and things like this?
PAUL HANSON: Yeah.
I've got some specs I've
got to read, because
I do a lot of research.
And I can see this is
an important area.
It looks like it's still
defining the actual specs at
the moment, but I presume
Android are getting fully
behind it, sort of thing.
NICK: Do you know anything
about it, Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: Not
any specifics.
My general read on that is that
that kind of thing is not
very Googly.
But if you are going to be doing
media codecs and playing
back licensed content from
people who own media titles,
you're going to have
to go there.
NICK: So at the moment, my take
on it, it's not a subject
I know a ton about.
But I believe there are some
devices already supported,
like in the Silicon already in
the market, like the Galaxy S3
and so forth.
And I think in some cases, we
even take advantage of it, I
think, maybe in some
of our DRM stuff.
I'm not entirely sure.
But I don't think there are
any platform APIs yet.
I think it's all quite device
specific at the moment.
where we're going to
be invoking native
libraries and so on.
PAUL HANSON: So you mentioned
the Galaxy S3.
What was in relation to the
Galaxy S3 you just mentioned?
Sorry, I missed that bit.
NICK: Sorry.
I think they support the ARM
TrustZone somehow, although
I'm not entirely sure.
I think I just heard
that anecdotally.
PAUL HANSON: OK.
No problem.
NICK: So it's not something I
know a ton about, I'm afraid.
PAUL HANSON: I might have some
stuff I'll write and message
over before the conference.
Or is there someone at the
conference who might be more
NFC, more security kind
of person down there?
NICK: Not from Google, no.
PAUL HANSON: OK.
NICK: Cool.
Any more live questions?
Or are we going to take a dive
into the Moderator queue?
SPARKY RHODE: Since you brought
it up before, maybe
you would like to take a minute
to tell us what you did
last weekend.
And what is that thing on
the wall behind you?
NICK: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I was visiting friends in Berlin
this weekend who were
holding a DevFest event.
A really nice little event
which was a DevFest.
Lots of talks about Google
technologies coupled with an
Android V Hack event as well.
So this is celebrating Android's
fifth birthday.
There's a bunch of Hackathons
going on culminating in a
final Hackathon in London
after Droidcon.
And one of the cool extra
things around Android's
birthday is, Marie Schweiz,
the awesome
designer, has painted--
you might be able to make
out over my shoulder--
a game board-- a Snakes and
Ladders style game where you
move around from
start to end--
depicting the life of Android.
So you've got Cupcakes and
Gingerbread men and Eclairs
and all this good
stuff in there.
So you can move around and slide
back down the Honeycomb
trail and so on.
It's beautiful.
I know she's trying
to get this turned
into a game, right?
MATT: Yep.
NICK: So if you go to
github.com/c-base--
C-B-A-S-E, or maybe C hyphen
B-A-S-E, I'm not sure--
there's an open source project
where they're, I think
AndEngine to turn this into a
playable game on your tablet
so you can have people
playing this game.
So if you have any spare time or
you're going to a Hackathon
and don't know what hack to work
on, then perhaps you can
contribute.
That would be an
awesome present
to the Android community.
MATT: It goes to all the
platforms, which will be
interesting.
SPARKY RHODE: It is
github.com/c-base.
NICK: Cool.
And it's called what,
birthday?
Fifth Android birthday?
Something--
SPARKY RHODE: Haven't
got that far yet.
MATT: I think it's like "Happy
fifth birthday."
NICK: But Yeah, I'm sure
all patches welcome.
MATT: I think Marie just
wants to see that
app boy go out really.
But yeah, if you need assets,
I think if you ping her,
you'll probably get response
pretty quick.
Yeah, it's looking good.
SPARKY RHODE: Well, thanks
for that update.
Should we take a Moderator
question then?
NICK: Let's do it.
Someone posted the link.
Github.com/c-bas
e/happy-fifth-birthday-android.
SPARKY RHODE: How nice.
NICK: Go for it, Sparky.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
So first unanswered question
on the Moderator--
activity hosting multiple
fragments.
Each fragment uses data
from the same
table of a local database.
Would it be better to load table
data into a singleton
POJO in activity rather than
loaders in each fragment?
How can activity broadcast
fragments on load complete?
This is Martin S.
He goes on to say, I know how
to use interface methods to
access data in activity
from the fragment.
I just don't know how the
activity can tell the fragment
it's loaded the data so that
the fragment can hide the
indeterminate progress
and paint the data.
Maybe loaders not that
much of a problem.
When each fragment needs the
data from web service, then it
makes sense for the
activity to do a
single web service call.
So this sounds like a familiar
design pattern to me.
You've got a data store.
You want to show it in possibly
multiple places, each
in a fragment.
And you've got this very long,
slow, method of getting the
data from the web, which
could take an
indeterminately long time.
It could take seconds or even
minutes to fetch the data.
This follows, I think, in the
pattern of like the RSS reader
app that I wrote earlier
this year.
And what I did to solve the
problem in that case was I
used a SQL database to host
the data locally.
I used a content provider to
publish it and then loaders so
that the loaders and the content
provider worked out
between themselves when the data
needed to be refreshed.
In that case, my fragments
really didn't have
to do a whole lot.
Now it is true that I did not
put any code into my detail
fragment to look for a change
in the data, because I was
expecting the data to
be quite static.
But the list view definitely
updated dynamically as the
database changed.
I did not do an indeterminate
progress.
Instead, basically, I just
fetched everything, more or
less, invisibly and just let the
new data magically appear
in the list view.
What I did for fetching the data
was not to put it in the
activity, but I put it
in an IntentService.
And then either a timer kicked
off by alarm manager or a user
interface button on the action
bar would cause an intent to
be sent to the IntentService
to go out to the web data
store and fetch new
data for me.
So my answer then was
IntentService for the web,
kicked off by intents from the
activity or from alarm
manager, SQL database to hold
the data, content provider to
front it, loader to keep it
fresh, and then one fragment
per to actually show the data.
MATT: Sounds good.
SPARKY RHODE: Rather a long
winded explanation, but I
don't see a lot of other
people vying for
our attention here.
NICK: Just speaking about the
general question he said about
how would you have the activity
talk to a fragment.
He says he understands that
you can use an interface
method that the activity
implements so that when the
fragment gets the unattached
message, it holds the
reference and casts the activity
to the interface.
So he understands
talking from the
fragment up to the activity.
But quite simply, the answer's
really simple really.
I think it's fine for the
activity to know concrete
details about the fragment.
It's just not OK for the
fragment to know concrete
details about the activity
as it were.
Because that destroys idea of
me having to lay out the
fragments differently.
But because activities own the
fragments within them, it's OK
to directly implement
call method.
So you can just--
when you create the fragment
and add it to the page in a
transaction, you just hold a
reference set fragment and
just invoke methods upon it.
So if you did decide to try
the loader held by the
activity rather than a loader
per fragment, you could just
invoke methods directly on
the fragment itself.
SPARKY RHODE: Sounds
good to me.
Shall we move on to the next
Moderator question?
The next one is this question
from Andrew Kelly about the
action bar.
I think we've heard
that one already.
OK.
Here's kind of a tempting one.
HTC just announced a five inch
phone with a 1920 by 1080
pixel resolution screen--
so 1080 P. This leads to
440 dots per inch.
How can this work?
And how can developers provide
drawables for this resolution?
XHDP is 320 and this
is 120 DPI more.
How big is the screen size
in DIPs for this phone?
So my first response to this
question was, oh my God.
I want this phone.
I provided a link
to it in the--
I provided a link to HTC's
product description.
And it is a very, very nice
looking phone, I have to say.
NICK: I'm opening that link.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, hello.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
So first off, you know that DIPs
basically translate to
real world units.
It's sort of a shorthand for
approximately inches or some
fraction thereof and that 160
dots per inch is the natural
standard for a DIP.
So at 160 DPI, you're
one DIP per pixel.
Generally speaking, phone
devices fall into the normal
sized bucket.
There is a bit of overlap in
our bucket sizes so that a
large phone and a small tablet
could be either normal sized
or large sized.
Generally speaking, you want
your small tablets to be in
the large sized bucket, and you
want your big phones to
still be in the normal sized
bucket, I think.
So I don't have any direct
information on this one at all
other than just looking at
HTC's press release.
But I would guess that
at this pixel count--
this 1920 by 1080--
you're looking at approximately
speaking 360
DIPs by 640 DIPs.
And it'll probably fall into
the XXHDPI density bucket,
which is something that was
added to the Android SDK for
SDK Level 16.
NICK: Wait.
Hang on.
But XX is what, for 480 DPI?
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
XXHDPI is 480 dots per inch.
NICK: So we probably wouldn't
get the XX drawables, because
it's not high enough.
The 440 would fall back to
XHDPI drawables, right?
SPARKY RHODE: These things
are always a little
bit flexible, right?
I mean it's not precisely, but
it's the closest density
bucket that matches the actual
density of the screen.
I think that 480 is a lot closer
to 440 than is 320,
which is the next
available size.
NICK: Huh.
OK.
SPARKY RHODE: So that's
kind of my take on it.
NICK: I thought it would
never round up.
I thought it would only
ever round down.
MATT: I'm with Sparky
on this one.
I think the documentation always
suggested it's roughly
around that.
NICK: OK.
I'm going to have to go and look
at their source code to
display manager.
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
Yes.
Definitely.
Another thing that I
noted is that it's
approximately twice--
so at 440 DPI, it's
approximately twice the
density of TV DPI.
So if you have TV DPI assets,
they could just about be
doubled, and it would
just about fit.
NICK: The idea of scaling
any asset up scares the
bejesus out of me.
SPARKY RHODE: Yes.
But that said, I mean if you
don't provide assets at the
right density--
NICK: It only scale down.
It would never scale up.
That's what I'm thinking of.
Yeah, you're right.
It would take the 480 asset
and scale them down.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
So you write an app that's
targeted at say medium DPI and
you run it on your Galaxy Nexus,
it's going to have to
take that low res asset
and display it
on a high res display.
So it's going to have
to do some doubling.
And my general take on this is,
if I'm going to have to be
scaling up an icon or something,
I would rather
double it than multiply by 1.5,
because I think you're
going to have fewer banding
and artifacts
and things like that.
NICK: The other thing that's
worth noting as well is that
the density buckets are
basically just aliases.
So I think at runtime AAPT
will just turn them into
numbers, right?
So when you have drawable dash
HDPI, it actually turns that
at runtime into drawable
dash 240 DPI.
So you can actually provide
numeric qualifiers.
So if supporting a device with
440 DPI is super important to
you, and your load DryIcon has
to look amazingly crisp on
that device, create a version
at the native resolution and
put it in the drawable
dash 440 DPI folder.
MATT: I did not know that.
Nice.
SPARKY RHODE: That is a
brilliant suggestion.
NICK: Why thank you.
But generally I would say you
only want to be scaling down.
So if you know what you're
doing, you can get pretty good
effects by just providing, say,
XHDPI graphics and have
that scaled down to HDPI and
MDPI devices by sticking to
like a 4 pixel major grid and
not having very small
elements, so that they
can be halved or
quartered relatively smoothly.
It can help you get
a lot of the way.
But there's no substitute for
actually producing the right
assets in different densities
and eye-balling them and
checking that they're correct,
and especially being careful
on 9-patches.
Because if you provide a 9-patch
in just one high
resolution and it gets scaled
down by the system to run on
say an [? LDVI ?]
device, you've got to
be real careful with
your stretchable regions.
If you only use one or two
pixels for your stretchable
region, that might get down
sampled and rounded down to
zero pixels, for example.
And all of a sudden, your
9-patch doesn't stretch.
So you want to make sure
your stretchable
areas are two or four--
I think four pixels would be
the safest, pretty much.
That's [? steep ?], but there's
no substitute for
producing proper densities,
especially for critical assets
like load DryIcons.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
And it's been my general
observation that photographs
scale up and down through
densities really, really well.
But finely hand drawn line art,
like what you typically
get in icons, doesn't
scale so well.
So for these little visual
assets like icons and widgets,
just go ahead and make them in
the right pixel sizes in the
first place.
Then of course, now that we've
potentially got-- what, five?
Wait, let's see.
Low, medium, high, extra high,
TV and double X. So we have
six potential density buckets.
Can't we just have scalable
vector graphics please?
No.
I've actually put
this question to
the framework engineers.
Why can't we just have SVG as
a first class drawable?
And it's just not that simple.
It would be really nice, but
it's not that simple.
NICK: There's a rudimentary spot
in that library, right?
The Android SVG project, which
I think was created for the
Androidify application.
I think those guys created
it and open sourced it,
which is very cool.
So that actually turns an SVG
into a native drawable, right?
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
And if I understand correctly,
that implements only part of
the SVG spec.
But if it's the right
part, I'll take it.
NICK: Wow.
I think we thoroughly answered
that question.
SPARKY RHODE: I hope so.
Jan Sosen, Brazil, who was in
our Hangout last week if I
recall, said, how can I launch
turn by turn navigation from
my application using intents?
It can be done.
It's not a publicly documented
API, especially with regards
to Google Maps Navigation.
That's definitely not public.
So we can't really
talk about it.
But we can at least observe that
other people say it can
be done, and stack overflow
is your friend.
NICK: Very, very nicely
done, Sparky.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARKY RHODE: Weasel, weasel.
What can I say?
I used to be a weasel keeper.
Weasel words are my specialty.
NICK: The other thing you can
do is launch to Maps, to the
destination where you are trying
to navigate to, because
that is a documented API.
That is on our developer site.
And then let the user hit the
Navigate to this Place button
themselves as an alternative.
SPARKY RHODE: I think that's
a very nice alternative.
Anything that has documented
API as part of
it is a good answer.
NICK: I love stuff which
links me out to Maps.
Anything talking about places.
I really love stuff that
links me out to--
well not just Maps, but using
the Geo intent, because then
other applications can
converge on that.
Like Google Earth, for example,
also offers to
satisfy those similar intents.
But it just means that every
time Maps gets better, then
your app gets better
kind of thing.
I love it.
SPARKY RHODE: That's
pretty cool.
Let's see.
Next question in the Moderator
is Andrew's question about the
animated launcher icon, which
we covered at the
beginning of the show.
MATT: There's an interesting
one in the Google+ stream.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh.
Please, do tell.
MATT: I have a question
regarding Nexus 7 from Faren
Garigerole.
Sorry if I pronounced
that wrong,
because I probably have.
My objective is that from the
native contacts, when I click
the call button on a contact
with the telephone number, my
application should pop
up as an option for
processing the call.
This is working on all phones
except the Nexus 7, which
doesn't receive the event.
Is there something that I need
to do special for Nexus 7?
NICK: Now that's an
interesting one.
SPARKY RHODE: This would
be a SIT phone I guess.
NICK: Yes.
MATT: Nick's trying it
out as we speak.
NICK: Skype's used to do it.
MATT: So they've included the
intent fields that they've got
and they're catching call
privileged, and they're trying
to catch the data scheme tel.
NICK: So it seems
to be possible.
I just tried it on my device,
and Skype popped up and
offered to execute
the call for me.
So it makes me think that
there's another end filter
you're not handling.
MATT: What I would recommend
doing is there's an Nexus
application called Sipdroid.
Try it out on the Nexus 7.
See if that catches it.
If it does, then perhaps
you can see what
filters they're using.
That's what I used when I'd see
something similar to this,
because there are quite
a few that they use.
So I can't remember
which ones.
But yeah, this will
make it specific.
NICK: Although I haven't
actually used kind of ugly app
on a device called Intent Hunt
or Intent something where you
could install it on you device,
and it will tell you
which intent filters your
applications you have
installed satisfy.
So you might be able to
use something like
this to look at Skype.
Because essentially it's
their public API.
So I don't know off hand, but
there's some pointers that
might get you going.
SPARKY RHODE: That's
a good idea.
We've just been joined in
the Hangout by Richard.
I can't read your last
name, I'm sorry.
Richard, welcome
to the Hangout.
Do you have a question about
Android development?
RICHARD: Can you hear me?
SPARKY RHODE: We can hear you.
RICHARD: Perfect.
First, I'm from Zambia.
It's an African country.
And I just got into Android.
I like the way it's so
structured, because these days
we have software which is
not really structured.
You just have people building it
with no sense of structure
that's there.
And I like the way Android
does it, because when
somebody's developing in
Android, they are forced to
have structure.
So that's what I wanted
to say for now.
SPARKY RHODE: Just out of
curiosity, would you like to
share with us what you're
working on?
RICHARD: I am working on a
social networking application
using NFC, because I like the
idea of I could be able to
share something on your wall
just by touching your phone.
I would like to try
that out actually.
NICK: Pretty cool.
SPARKY RHODE: That
is a cool idea.
Are using the Android
Beam API for that?
RICHARD: Yes.
I am going to use Android
Beam API.
But I'm just mapping it out to
get the requirements first.
Then I'll dive deep into it.
SPARKY RHODE: Well let us
introduce you to Paul Hanson
who is right next to you in the
icon bar at the bottom of
my screen who is an NFC
fellow traveler.
PAUL HANSON: Hello.
RICHARD: Hello.
How's it going?
PAUL HANSON: Good, thank you.
It sounds quite interesting,
your project, with the NFC.
Have you actually implemented
much NFC before?
RICHARD: No, actually.
It will be my first
experience.
It will be also like a
learning experience.
PAUL HANSON: Did you hear
me OK for that, sorry.
RICHARD: Yes I did, actually.
PAUL HANSON: Yes, I'm still
learning about the limitations
and restrictions of how
far we can go with
it for future projects.
So it's interesting your
angle on it as well.
RICHARD: Oh yes, actually.
PAUL HANSON: I was listening
in before, sorry.
RICHARD: No, that's OK.
I feel like it's a growing
technology, because I think
it's going to be used in so many
places, especially with
the Google Wallet.
And the ideas that you can
come up with are just
phenomenal.
NICK: Yeah.
I'm with you guys from
a UX point of view.
I really love the way that
Android Beam is implemented
and that there's no on-screen
affordance.
You literally just touch and
then it will send whatever is
in the foreground.
I love that simplicity.
Basically using such a close
location as a really strong
signal that you don't have to
have lots of guides and
buttons and things
to hinder it.
That's one of the things I'm
really excited about.
PAUL HANSON: I've actually been
asked about that element
of the Beam where you have to
touch on the interface.
I've been asked is there a way
of transferring via NFC
without the touch.
Obviously the Beam will force
you to make the person touch.
But there are some circumstances
where you might
want to do a back and forth
conversation, and you may not
want to touch each time.
But I think the Beam
forces each time.
NICK: Yes.
If you're using Beam, the Beam
is like a convenience API on
top of NFC.
So yeah, if you wanted
to use Beam, then the
touch is part of that.
But you can obviously build
that kind of transceiving
behavior using the lower
level NFC tech.
PAUL HANSON: Yes.
That's what I was looking
at, because that was
the only to do that.
Yes.
Thank you.
NICK: No worries.
PAUL HANSON: I've
got a question
for Richard in Zambia.
I just wondered how many phones
actually have the NFC
chip in your country
at the moment?
Or do you know what
the take up is?
RICHARD: I am actually
doing school in
Canada at the moment.
So I wouldn't be too
sure about it.
But I could find out.
PAUL HANSON: OK.
Well actually, in Canada,
what percentage--
is the take up very high on the
phones with the NFC chips
in at the moment, I guess?
RICHARD: It should be pretty
high, because in the place
that I'm living in, it's a small
town called Kamloops .
It's like everybody wants to
have the newest phone.
It's like almost everybody's
mesmerized by that Galaxy
commercial.
Like, oh my god, they're
touching phones.
That is really, really cool.
So I think a large percentage
should have that .
NICK: Good news is, it seems to
be getting built into most
of these systems on
a chip set up.
So most phones these days, or
at least the high end ones
seem to be coming with it.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I'm sort of going out on a limb
a little bit here, but I
suspect a lot of it is just
a matter of economies of
manufacture where you're going
to want to concentrate your
analog electronics all into one
place, which means you're
going to want to have all your
different radio processors on
the same chip.
And once you're doing that,
you've got your
telephone-based band and your
Wi-Fi and your Bluetooth all
on the same chip.
Might as well throw in the NFC
too and just be done with it.
MATT: The one thing that I
haven't spent much time
playing around with is the
new NFC cards, which they
announced a little while ago.
I managed to grab
a small batch of
those from those guys.
And they were quite fun.
Wandering around I think I got
Paul [INAUDIBLE] quite
interested with the
[? Cake Droid. ?]
I think he wanted
a set for them.
But yeah, there seems to be a
lot of people playing around
with NFC and seeing what
they can do with it.
PAUL HANSON: Can you tell me
a bit about those cards?
What are they exactly
called please?
MATT: There's a company called
Moo, which is in the US as
well as the UK.
SPARKY RHODE: Which Moo
as in cow, right?
Moooo.
NICK: Yeah.
Moo.com.
Moo.
MATT: And they do customized
business cards.
The cool thing with them is that
you can print a different
image on the front
of each card.
They're playing around
with NFC.
I don't think it's
released yet.
NICK: I think it's on sale.
MATT: Oh really.
Cool.
I wasn't sure if they've
released it.
But yeah.
Go check them out.
They seem like a pretty
cool kind of product.
NICK: I think that--
I can't remember which
standard they are.
They're one of the standard--
I think they might be MIFARE.
Although I'm probably wrong.
Can't remember.
But there's a super
standard card.
And they're not locked.
They're read-writable.
So you can use NXP tag writer
app, for example, just to push
different stuff.
And one of the coolest things
about Moo with their
manufacturing processes is that
they can put different
tags in different cards as well,
which is kind of cool.
So you can get like five
different designs.
Like this one has my
contact details on.
This one has a Google Maps link
to get you to my office.
And this one has a YouTube
play list, URL, whatever.
Pretty cool.
SPARKY RHODE: Nice.
So I've pasted the URL for
them in the sidebar here.
It's us.moo.com/nfc.
NICK: Good British company.
MATT: So, Moderator question?
SPARKY RHODE: We're getting
down there.
There's not a whole lot left.
Let's see.
I think this is the new one.
This was submitted since
the Hangout started.
So I didn't answer it.
In list view, I have custom rows
with progress bars and
buttons on each.
How can I get info from the row
the button was pressed to
start some calculations
and update
progress bar in this row?
Similar behavior like
Google Play app.
We get this kind of a lot.
I see a lot of questions in
stack overflow that are all
talking about wanting to put
buttons into their list views.
So it's a pretty popular
pattern.
I don't know.
My first response is, why
would you do that?
I mean why would you replicate
a control over and over and
over again like that when
you could just make
the list view clickable?
But I guess the answer is just
a custom layout, right?
NICK: He's already doing that I
think, by the sounds of it.
MATT: I think he wants to know
how he knows what the index is
once the button's
been clicked.
I think my default behavior to
solve this is if you're using
the ViewHolder pattern, stash
the index in a ViewHolder and
then when the button is clicked,
catch the click in
the ViewHolder and then have a
separate listener which parses
out saying, this is the index
of what I am, and I've just
been clicked.
But, yeah, I'm kind of
with you, Sparky.
It's not a good thing to do.
NICK: Now I don' t
know about this.
I think there's definite ways
you would want to put a button
in there of different
clickable regions.
Think about in the People
app, for example.
You have a list item which
is partly phone numbers.
So tapping [INAUDIBLE], it
will call them, and then
there's a little divider.
And then like the SMS phone.
I think this is a common
pattern where you have
multiple actions per row.
I think it's perfectly valid.
So yeah, you basically want
it to respond to a click.
I think if you're using a
list-activity, for example,
then you get the un-item
selected callback, which will
actually give you the
position as well.
So that's the index
into your adapter.
MATT: But I guess that applies
to the whole row, doesn't it?
Or am I--
NICK: Yeah, but you also get a
view of those taps as well.
MATT: Good point.
SPARKY RHODE: Sounds like
a good answer to me.
For my own part, it's one of
those, why would I want to
know how to do that?
I wouldn't want to do that.
NICK: If I recall correctly as
well, Mr. Cyril Mottier of
Green Droid fame, did a series
of really, really great blog
posts about tips and tricks
on list views.
And I think this is one of the
topics he covered about how to
have differentially, separately
clickable areas
within a list row.
And so I will either search
for Cyril Mottier, Android
blog, list view perhaps.
Or we can try and put out
that link as well.
SPARKY RHODE: Sure.
Actually I found
it right here.
NICK: Wow.
That was quick.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
It's Cyril Mottier Tips and
Tricks #4, add several
clickable areas.
That sounds pretty
close to me.
So here is the URL.
NICK: Do you want to
pop that in the
Moderator as well in case?
Who is it who asked?
Yeah.
In case Martin from Poland isn't
watching, we should pop
that in the Moderator as well.
Thank you Cyril, for writing
out that great info.
SPARKY RHODE: Awesome.
MATT: It's a pretty cool
trick, I must admit.
NICK: Yep.
Use it responsibly.
Like Sparky says, many times a
better solution is to have the
whole list item clickable.
But if there are separately two
actions you want to have
in the list item then--
I don't know exactly which list
you are referring to in
Google Play client.
There are a few.
Perhaps it's the
new behaviors.
I haven't got that.
When you look at your list of
all installed apps, you can
now get rid of stuff
from that.
So all those apps which you
were just trying out--
honestly, you don't use the
Taylor Swift app or whatever--
you can now get it out of
your install history.
Maybe that will be an example of
where you have a list item
which is mostly clickable, and
then a section at the end
which does a secondary action.
Cool.
So unless we have any questions,
what do we do?
Wrap up early?
Give everyone some time back?
Shoot the breeze?
Any more questions?
SPARKY RHODE: Just one little
final thought in response to
what you were just saying about
the secondary actions.
I just can't let that go without
suggesting also that
there's also perhaps a fair
argument to be made for going
with a long press rather
than having
multiple clickable regions.
Other than that, yeah.
MATT: I guess it comes down to
how [? discoverable ?] you
want the action to be.
If you think it's not a common
enough use case to warrant
actually taking up some space,
then long press is probably a
nicer solution to it.
I must admit, I hadn't
even considered the
context that way.
Yes, it's perfectly--
SPARKY RHODE: That or you can
make it a checkable list item,
and then you can check
it and have an action
on the action bar.
NICK: Well long press to launch
the [? contacts ?]
[? action ?] bar is pretty
standard as well.
I quite like just long press.
Especially because it
lets you do multiple
selections, which I love.
And we talked about that quite
a lot yesterday on Design in
Action, in case you missed it.
Cool.
All right.
Well everyone gets 15 minutes
of their day back.
How about that?
SPARKY RHODE: Well thanks,
everyone, for tuning in.
It's been our pleasure to talk
Android development with you,
and we look forward to seeing
you again at the next Hangout.
NICK: Thanks everyone.
Thanks for the good questions.
See you next week.
MATT: Cheers.
NICK: See you next week.